I think people get mixed up when they
saw so you can have four wives you have
to be able to afford four words yes
that's why it's a different yeah you
need to treat the people the men that
I've known that have got other families
they both nobody's suffering they all
and you find that the reason why they
don't want to leave the wife is because
they've been together for years and
finishing their houses and children in
college and everything grandchildren but
I've known people about secret family
tucked away and nobody suffers because
exactly what those kids are getting is
exactly what those kids are getting
[Music]